[Music]
the original Barbie doll collection was
created by Ruth handler who said she
wanted kids around the world to feel
they can be whoever they want to be but
over the years countries around the
world started creating alternatives to
these Barbies that would embody the
culture and represent their ethnicity
wait until you see these dolls that were
created to represent the Islamic values
you'll be amazed by this new definition
of beauty make sure you never miss one
of our videos by clicking the red
subscribe button today we are talking
about 10 amazing Barbies from around the
world build Lily doll from Germany aka
the doll that started it all did you
know that this doll wasn't intended for
children at all it was one of those joke
gifts you would give to your best
friends and many would often get them as
a present at their bachelorette party it
was sold in tobacco shops and bars and
it even had its own slightly
inappropriate comic book after a while
it finally sparked more interest with
the children that it did with adults the
bill Lily doll was just 1 foot tall it
had bleached blonde hair curves and a
lot of makeup but little did the Germans
know that this doll will soon take over
the entire world well sort of the dog
caught the eye of a 15 year old Barbara
handler whose mother was the co-founder
of the Mattel toy company they brought
three of these dolls back home and three
years later the very first Barbie doll
collection was introduced at the
American International Toy Fair in New
York did you know that Barbie is
actually named by Barbara handler who
first saw the dolls in Germany many of
the build Lily dolls features
transferred on to the Barbie doll
although Ruth handler seemed to improve
a lot of things this includes creating
removable shoes and making sure the toy
is seen more than just entertainment for
adults Muslim Barbie this Barbie got a
Muslim makeover that got everyone
talking it's called the hi Jovie Barbie
and it was created by the 24 year old
hanifa Adam from Nigeria hanifa simply
wanted to create a Barbie doll that
dresses the same way she did and since
the original Barbie collection doesn't
feature Muslim Barbies she decided to do
the job herself hanifa went to the store
bought a doll and started documenting
her idea on an Instagram account
she called hijab' although the company
behind
Barbie's brought new Barbie skintones
eye colors
hair styles and body type to bring
awareness to culture and diversity we
have yet to see Arabic dolls in their
collection this is because Barbie was
actually outlawed in Saudi Arabia as it
promotes non Islamic ideals this is why
Saudi Arabia created their own Barbie
doll called
hula she comes with her own prayer mat
and a large range of accessories her
clothing depends on where you buy her
and you can also find food in Egypt and
Indonesia hula was originally released
in 2003 but has proven to be a huge
success
by 2005 1.5 million fula dolls were sold
across the Middle East
pulip a Barbie doll from South Korea
pulip dolls are a South Korean version
of Barbie dolls they're fashionable and
completely customizable a pulip doll has
a large head and big eyes with a
mechanism that makes them able to look
from side to side as well as blink they
were first introduced in 2003 and since
then a range of over 200 pulip dolls has
been released they also come with a
boyfriend which was first released in
2004 his name is namu but unfortunately
he wasn't as popular as these little
fashionistas he got discontinued just a
year later then a new boyfriend came
along called Taeyang and this one is
here to stay
the pulip family also comes with a
sister called doll a vest friend Byul
younger brother is soon and yo loom who
is pullips future daughter the range
keeps on developing and new dolls are
released almost every month you can
easily make your own cool up and choose
your custom eye color change her hair
clothing and body the company behind
pulip also frequently releases limited
edition dolls it has even created a
Sailor Moon doll as well as other
characters from the anime culture queens
of Africa dolls from Nigeria in an
attempt to bring awareness to the
diversity of the original Barbie dolls
Nigerian entrepreneur Tawfik Akua
created a new line of dolls back in 2007
these dolls highlight the diversity of
skin tones and hair texture all while
rocking contemporary African fashion
they are called queens of Africa
it only reconfirmed the need for diverse
dolls when the queens of Africa outsold
the original Barbie dolls in 2014
Vic was inspired to create these dolls
after his own daughter expressed her
desire to have the same skin tone as the
original Barbie he felt the need to
educate young girls about the importance
of being yourself regardless of where
you come from the Queen's of Africa's
motto is to empower the African girl
child they're modeled after three main
African tribes and each Queen has a
different symbol love peace and
endurance and he's not stopping just a
dolls his team is also creating
educational books that teach children
self-confidence and cultural pride they
are also aiming to expand the doll line
and include at least one doll for each
African country along with creating
limited edition dolls to raise funds for
an African education charity
Lottie dolls from Ireland Lottie dolls
are Island's alternative to the famous
Barbie doll with an aim to empower
children to be themselves the company
behind Lottie dolls created dolls that
look like real nine-year-old children
these dog characters are completely
relatable and age-appropriate they
represent different facets of childhood
without any limitation a lot a dog comes
with a diverse range of skin hair and
clothing the world they live in is
called the Banksy Island which is
loosely based on UK's Brown Sea Island
which is the birthplace of many famous
story lines and movements including
Scouts and Girl Guides the company
behind the dolls spent months working
with kids their parents child
psychologists and more to truly
understand the children's world and
their needs they wanted to protect
childhoods and stop children from
wanting to grow up too soon this is why
Allah Diesel does not wear makeup and
isn't wearing high heels Loni dogs also
highlight women power their education
resources include great women
biographies for kids which includes
people like Jane Austen Emily Dickson
and Eleanor Roosevelt to quote the
company she can stand on her own two
feet
bodies tagline is to be bold be brave be
you Lottie dolls from Ireland mum be in
poppy from South Africa with a mission
to change beauty ideals and young women
made Mageau be' launched her line of mum
pee in poppy dolls in June 2014
unlike Barbie and other black dolls on
the market
mami and papi celebrates African girls
lush wooly hair its coyly curls
sunkissed golden skin and african
fabulousness
these dolls took over a year to make the
founder says she's still trying to find
new ways to feature their diversity to
change the meaning of beautiful the name
behind the dolls comes from merging the
meaning of the word doll in South Africa
Mae said she wants to open the minds of
little girls and let them see and
embrace their own beauty without calling
it exotic or dark beauty these dolls
portray the true African story from how
they dress to how their character will
develop as the company expands the
founder hopes that mom P and papi will
open up the African world to little
girls around the world as it is a
country that is often misrepresented and
misunderstood the country is also
looking into creating boy characters in
hopes to let go of stigma that a doll is
just a little girl's toy tree change
dolls from Australia these dolls are a
little bit different and their success
was surprising even to their founder
Sonia Singh starting off as a craft
project Sonia is now fully devoted to
the collection she calls tree change
dolls these dolls have been rescued and
recycled from there is shops around
Tasmania Sonia swapped their previous
lifestyle to something far more
relatable and down-to-earth she removed
the factory paint and decided to give
them what she calls a makeunder by hand
her mom an expert knitter and sower
created their clothing Sonia documented
her creations on her tumblr blog and
soon her work started going viral and
she got the world's attention she said
that she seems to have triggered a
global conversation about the
suitability and style of some children's
toys however Sonia wants to keep the
creativity in her project and refuses to
mass-produce it as it would lose the
meaning to the original idea instead of
turning her work into a full-time
company Sonia wants other people to take
action she created a guide to how you
can restyle your own dolls and has
crochet and knitting patterns available
on her Etsy site Japan's Ally catch an
this 8 inch doll started taking over
Japan in 1967 it was created by the
Takara company whose motto is plain is
ko
sure like a Chan is 11 years old goes to
junior high school and has a variety of
interests that have changed over the
years
she's very family-oriented and has twin
sisters and younger siblings that are
triplets other versions of Laika Chan
included a pregnant adult doll that was
a tribute to Crown Princess Masako she
was at the time pregnant with her
daughter ie Co despite her young age the
like Agha has several different career
outfits and special editions such as the
famous hat Sumi Miku doll one of the
coolest like adults ever is the
award-winning triple color change like a
tan the doll changes her hair color
according to the temperature but there's
an even bigger mystery to this cute
looking doll according to the urban
legends throwing away your like a Chan
means it will come back for revenge
Sarah and DA from Iran Muslim Sarah and
Dara dolls were created with an idea to
promote traditional pro-family
backgrounds and modest clothing that's
in line with Islamic values they were
introduced by the Institute for the
intellectual development of children and
young adults a government agency that
works with the Ministry of Education as
Barbie dolls were pretty much foreign to
Iran's culture the public welcomed the
new Iranian Barbie dolls the Sarah and
Dara dolls are also featured in school
books and stories which are available to
be purchased with the dolls Sarah and
Dara a boy and a girl are eight-year-old
siblings that are young enough to appear
without a headscarf under the Islamic
law but despite that all four models of
these dolls do come with head scarfs and
two outfits the toy makers said it took
five years to create these dolls as they
wanted to make sure the public will be
just as enthusiastic about them as they
are for that exact reason these dolls
are actually produced in China where
modern technology is more advanced but
Iran does plan to bring quality
technology into the country Sarah and I
are a direct response to the popular
Barbie and Ken which are far more
expensive in the country with an average
monthly salary of $100 you can purchase
these dolls for $15 while a Barbie doll
will cost $40 Barbies around the world
collection Mattel the company behind the
original Barbie doll definitely hears
the demands from their international
customers
in an attempt to bring awareness to
diversity and ethnicity Mattel the
company behind the Barbie doll create
his series of Barbies around the world
these dolls embrace their ethnicity and
show off the nation's traditional values
you can even find Hawaiian Barbie dolls
which come complete with a lei and a
muumuu the traditional Hawaiian dress
the first African American Barbie called
Christy was created back in 1968 but it
wasn't until 1980 that Mattel started
expressing different cultures and
nationalities through the Barbie dolls
1980 was the year of the Italian Barbie
which belonged to the dolls of the world
collection this collection currently
represents more than 40 nations across
all continents but the problem remains
all Barbies were the same size after all
these years and after a lot of feedback
from nations around the world Mattel has
finally completely embraced the fact
that people do come in different shapes
sizes and skin colors the true diversity
and a shift in the Barbie doll
production didn't come until 2016 when
Mattel launched fashionista Barbies they
are now available in four body types 7
skin tones 8 eye colors and 18 hair
styles and it paid off the Barbie sales
rose by 16 percent since the launch of
the diverse fashionistas collection
what's your favorite Barbie doll you've
ever owned let us know in the comments
below don't forget to click that thumbs
up button and subscribe to never miss a
video from us again for more videos like
this one check out the amazing evolution
of iconic children's toys see you next
time
[Music]